le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
s'investir dans la vie citoyenne et
défendre ses idées lorsqu'on est au
collège c'est possible le département de
la réunion est l'un des premiers à avoir
instauré le conseil départemental des
jeunes chaque année des collégiens des
quatre coins de l'île sont élus pour
représenter leurs camarades
parmi eux jade ludovic maria ou encore
métis mène avec passion et conviction d
action civique et sociale sur le terrain
dans l'hémicycle du département pour le
conseil du jour pas de porte documents
ni de costumes place au sac à dos et au
basket
aujourd'hui les représentants ont entre
13 et 15 ans et sont encore au collège
tous font partie du conseil
départemental des jeunes
un dispositif qui vise à encourager
l'expression et l'initiation à la
citoyenneté des collégiens chaque année
deux élèves de 4e et 3e sont élus pour
représenter leur établissement
jade est en 3e au collège de
montgaillard à saint denis
elle est la présidente du conseil depuis
novembre dernier
je pouvais m'exprimer delémont ressenti
et mener des actions qui me tiennent
vraiment à coeur je me suis dit pourquoi
pas - pourquoi je ne pourrais pas
justement être le porte parole de des
collégiens et mener des actions qui me
tiennent à coeur et aux autres
collégiens aussi sûrement ensemble les
jeunes représentants ont défini les
actions qu'il voulait mener tout au long
de l'année
l'un des thèmes retenus c'est celui de
la sécurité routière
pour ce conseil ils ont invité la
sous-préfète et le représentant des
forces de l'ordre pour débattre du sujet
réunion de commission pour chaque
secteur dans plusieurs commissions le
thème avait déjà été proposée la
sécurité routière et ben en vue
justement que le thème a été proposé
plusieurs fois on a on a gardé cette
thématique là parce qu'on est tous de
plus en plus les jeunes
on a juste allumer la télévision le soir
et comme disait tout à l'heure
madame la sous-préfète on entendait des
morts et des blessés routiers tous les
jours malheureusement et on constate que
c'est énormément de jeunes
des présentations des débats mais ce que
les jeunes préfèrent ce sont les actions
sur le terrain le conseil départemental
des jeunes offre une dégustation et donc
ça va se passer
cela transforme là-bas au parc du
colosse à saint-andré les collégiens
participent à une journée sportive de
sensibilisation à la nutrition et la
santé
22 le but de cette jeune et elle avec
l'una cesse de tous les collèges et
lucette et le conseil départemental des
jeunes guinée pour sensibiliser les
jeunes sur la nutrition jeunes de venir
nous voir pour avant des fruits juste
après on va faire leur sport on a des
ananas on a des mandats et des bananes
donc vous êtes les bienvenus investi et
dynamique
les jeunes porte parole font la fierté
de leurs aînés nous sommes le premier
département français à la réunion avoir
créé en 1989
un conseil départemental des jeunes et
aujourd'hui nous comptons à peu près
cent cinquante six collégiens qui
participent aux différentes actions
solidarité en faveur des publics les
plus démunis
j'ai été agréablement surprise de voir
l'intérêt que ces jeunes ces jeunes
collégiens attache à aider les gens qui
sont en difficulté vraiment mener des
actions en proximité d'un public pas
atassi évident vraiment en grande
demande en grande détresse sociale
je peux être que ravis que d'encourager
et d'accompagner ces jeunes à se
surpasser et bien sûr à se rendre utile
à notre société
vous savez on peut se passer
le conseil départemental des jeunes j'en
avais déjà entendu parler partager leurs
idées leurs expériences et faire
connaître le conseil départemental des
jeunes c'est une autre mission que se
sont fixés les représentants grecs nous
tient beaucoup à coeur de montrer de
couffé de montre aussi que des jeunes
peuvent s'investir pour des choses c'est
très important
en tout cas on fait des choses très
intéressantes et vous êtes cordialement
invités pour la dégustation de fruits
qui a lieu au soudan à notre sens de
conseil départemental des jeunes on vous
attend on peut communiquer avec
plusieurs jeunes on peut enfin passer un
message montrer que la jeunesse
réunionnaise
elle est capable de faire autre chose et
qu'elle veut devenir quelque chose de
bien
c'est qu'il n'y a qu à l'expérience
parce que ça m'a aidé vraiment à savoir
ce que je voulais faire donc dépendre
les causes qui me tiennent à coeur et
être un porte parole donc voila c'était
une expérience est inoubliable
le conseil départemental des jeunes
permet aux collégiens de 3e et 4e de
s'exprimer et d'agir pour des thèmes qui
leur tiennent à coeur
chaque année un suppléant est un
titulaire sont élus dans chaque collège
galilée pour représenter leur
établissement
encadrés par une équipe du département
les jeunes conseillers participent à des
commissions pour définir leur projet à
des assemblées plénières pour élire leur
président et voter ces projets puis à
des actions de terrain
si vous souhaitez en savoir plus sur le
conseil départemental des jeunes
vous pouvez vous rendre sur le site du
département au www.cn.ca 4 point fr
m